his quote is just so outstanding he says
did my genitalia go unnoticed
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
[Music]
[Applause]
i worked in northridge at
teledyne in 82
they did like aerospace thing and there
was a guy his name was richard millard
and he was skinny and he wore
like a khaki top and bottom to work
and he'd walk sidewinder and he'd talk
like elmer fudd
he'd say come you guys got to come over
here
and he had a camel he bought a cavalier
from the dealership on devonshire
because the guy said listen matt this
car's such a good deal
if you don't buy it i'm going to buy it
and he bought it oh no katie
and uh he he was the first person
that i ever heard that had ibs
and everybody knew that whenever you saw
those little feet and the khaki pants
sit down next to you to get
out of there cause that dude was gonna
blow
that thing up before you even knew what
ibs
was which i don't even know what's the
cause of it
i have no idea myself that duo
i would i would go because i was so
anti-social that i would
i was reading that no one gets out of
here alive the jim morrison
autobiography and i would go to the last
stall during my lunch break and sit in
the last stall
and read the book and when richard
miller came in there i'll tell you man
no one gets out alive
[Laughter]
poor guy man anybody living with ibs
or pancreatitis or diverticulitis
yeah all those things that
are just destroy your bowels so he
wasn't just loud he was
aroma oh like smell horrible that i'd be
horrible
to have oh my god one time ernie said
wake me we were
we were at my grandma's house we were
gonna watch kiss on the midnight special
and he said wake me up before it starts
i put my finger
right in my cuda crack i put it under
his nose like i was like
smelling salts he punched the air he was
like he was sitting down
on the carpet like that and i went like
that
[Laughter]
you know you should never get too old to
not either have fun
or don't ever let anybody disrespect you
like at the golf course when i hit that
ball sideways
i didn't yell four the ladies were
playing and that guy goes hey buddy your
your ball's over here and then his wife
was talking spanish to the girls at the
that work at the turn and she's not you
know she was like
and i and i rolled up behind him and i
said don't you guys speak english and
they
both smiled and they looked at me and
she said that ball almost hit us and i
said almost
nice nice keyword yeah right to be that
old and to be a piece of [ __ ]
is you should be quite proud of yourself
to just
create tension for the sake of creating
tension
right people thrive that way
they love that [ __ ] man they just love
to and over there
in the desert all people will go to a
restaurant
and then complain about the service to
try to get
a free meal oh my gosh that's cool and
that's like a routine of
uh i had a buddy to do that remember i
told you when i worked at the
i worked at the convolution i worked at
a convalescent home
and i would bring you know the old guys
oatmeal
and they would say i'm not hungry or i
would come back in i said hey you didn't
eat your oatmeal
and he goes i'm not hungry so i started
i said listen you [ __ ] old
[ __ ]
i'm gonna walk outside right now and i'm
gonna go
drop off some linens i'll be back in
five minutes and if that oatmeal
isn't eaten and completely gone i'm
gonna take that [ __ ] remote
and i'm gonna crack you in the middle of
your [ __ ] forehead with it
now and begin
huh listen when a person is an invalid
grab that [ __ ] by his wrist and
time to get his [ __ ] together
okay
don't worry about me my grandma's like
what's going on in there i'm jacking up
what the [ __ ] is going on and that's how
it starts
uh george's guest today is you've seen
him
in hundreds of movies you know what i
haven't seen him in hundreds of [ __ ]
movies because
he's a person that's not known that's
what i'm saying you didn't know you saw
him when you saw him he's one of
the greatest stunt performers slash
stunt coordinators
in the business right yeah bond movies
born movies
guardians of galaxy just to say a few
yeah absolutely i've been very lucky
yeah all right the guest today
is craig frosty silva we call him frosty
ladies and gentlemen
okay so frosty and i met was it 10 years
ago 11 years ago yes
at the chateau marmont yep uh
and he walked over and we just started
talking
connected and i said what do you do and
he was telling me some stories about
being a stunt man
and it's funny man when you meet
somebody
that whatever the chemistry is between
two people
he and i maybe don't talk all the time
but we
always checked in on each other and
that's like a rare thing like i don't do
that
but with frosty map is always like hey
dude you all right and then once we
started doing this
i thought this dude would be a great guy
to have on because
i don't you know i want the people that
you don't
wouldn't expect because their lives are
fascinating and they're real
and they're not [ __ ] they're not
about money
it's about guts perseverance
and just a fearlessness that
very few people have in life much less
in in films so
he's going to be here the whole the
whole hour um
did green screen change the stunt
i it can absolutely because you can put
it anywhere right you can do all these
stunts it depends on how they use them
uh green screen has really changed
obviously for superhero films and you
know that's all the way they do them now
uh but it's useful in in a certain way
practical stunts sadly the big huge
practical stunts aren't done as much
anymore because
it's just expensive there's risk they do
a lot of stuff on green screen
they cg a lot of stuff in now you know
they said
ian mcallen sir ian mckellen
was doing the ring or one of those
movies and he showed up to work and he
was
acting with like a piece of tape or a
tennis ball on top of a c-stand
and he he didn't under he didn't realize
he wasn't going to be working with an
actor that they were going to do that
later
and he started crying oh my god because
he loved his profession so much
and he's like is this what it's come
down to is looking at a piece of tape
and talking to somebody who's not there
and he cried
yeah there's a well the new thing there
they're they scan you
so they can put you technically they
have all your information your body i
mean it's you
on a computer they could put you in 40
different films
oh yes i've got a ton of films this year
did you know that did you know
did you know that sam jackson like broke
his shoulder almost could have could
have killed himself
no they were doing a stunt where they
were picking him up and he was either
like in a box and i don't know why
he would be in the box but then the
thing let go and it fell and it
crushed his shoulder like a complete
break oh wow no i didn't know that you
don't ever want to put your lead actor
in a situation like that
there's no reason for him to be in that
box no there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of ego obviously in this
business you know the machoness and
you know male and female there you know
it doesn't matter which way it is
everyone's got a bit of an ego which
kind of drives you and it's kind of what
you need in this business is kind of
what
puts you against everyone in the sense
of like oh i can do this better
i know i could do that you know and so
you do try to
you do try to push that side of you yeah
but it it
there's a lot of guys that just aren't
ready for it and sadly when the industry
opened up in atlanta
they wanted to hire locals you know and
you just don't get the same but can you
find local stuntmen in atlanta
uh yeah they'll make them local stuntmen
and then
you have to try to hopefully get you
know a lot of guys did move out there so
you can find
good guys still but when you want a
large quantity of guys you don't have
that option
and that was the problem when the
industry started leaving la
but you know when you look at hollywood
and you look at movies you might
talk about like the leading man like
humphrey bogart
or you know cagney and you look at like
tom cruise
you look at george clooney or you look
at beautiful actresses
but you forget that the magic of making
movies
and flying and the wizard of oz
and all those things and movies that
like bullet
steve mcqueen stuff or jason bourne
which i love
that the stunned person
smoking the all those the stunt person
is
almost like you hear you hear the glue a
lot
but it's almost like the plate
that holds hollywood together because
the magicalness of a movie or the
mysticism or the
the lady from the wizard of oz is flying
and the [ __ ] green makeup almost
kills her yeah yeah exactly figuring it
out
that that that through all the time of
movies
with the whole larger than life ah
people forget that that's a stunt person
yeah and the guy the guy or the girl
gets the credit but
that person spent hours and hours and
hours
perfecting it so they would so they
would get it right and it wouldn't go
wrong because
when it goes right it goes right you
don't get credit for going right
but when they go awry so
every everybody knows everyone knows
stunt gone wrong is how they
stunt gone wrong is how they normally so
when you let's say
uh run run through the preparation of a
of a stunt and how many times
you might some person might do it a
stunt person might well it depends
on what it is like say if it's a car
we'll get a stunt person obviously to do
that kind of wreck
if it unless you're tom cruise which you
know he's the producer of his film so
no one's going to tell him no hence he
does his he does do his own stunts it's
tested you think it's because
scientologists like he's
like zeon is going to come and touch his
shoulders don't worry man
you could breathe underwater do you know
who i am i can't get hurt
okay in your opinion uh i mean can you
even say this because you work
on his films is he a a worthy stunt he's
a good stunt man
he'd actually be he's probably done
eighty percent
more stunts than a lot of stunt guys
he'd be a great stuntman oh no he's
actually oh yeah
yeah the guy's a hard worker i mean we
we aren't the same type of person really
but uh he's a super i mean the guy's
just working constantly working yeah it
sounds like you know so so
um if an actor said like tom cruise says
hey you know i want to do my own stunts
he does that because of the real realism
of the movie
and you don't want to see um maybe if he
jumps
a couple of those things that you're
sure that you you you see that it really
is him hanging from a helicopter or
jumping from a building with a wire and
then crashing through the window i mean
come on man
i mean he's brilliant he's he's ballsy
the guy will go for it
every time but it is it's a risk and
you have a chance of if you hurt your
actor you're done
you know your show's done for a while
until he he gets better unless you have
a great double for him
but it it it can it can be trying that
way because there's nothing harder
than sitting there waiting for your
actor maybe to hurt himself you know and
as a sun coordinator you're
you're trapped you just have to sit and
watch stressful this
possible tragedy happened so we were
talking about once upon a time in
hollywood and and
you said that that was really kind of
based on burt reynolds and hal needham
who was a stunt man and director of like
smoking abandon cannonball run
and helnidom died while doing a stunt
didn't no
no he just died of older dar robinson
did dar robinson
oh i thought it was hal nina okay yeah
robinson robinson
sadly passed away and how did he what
happened to him um you know
there's a few stories of it i guess the
the one i heard
was um basically it was it was coming
back to one
after a stunt and something happened on
the motorcycle he was riding
and he tumbled down a hill and i guess
he got impaled going down that hill
and he bled out before they could get to
him but you know he
he was alive and aware until they just
couldn't get to him in time
how did you become a stunt man and what
was the first stunt
you did and then after that we'll go to
some stories
um yeah you know it's kind of one of
those things every every boy wants to
i'm going to be
well you did when you were you probably
wanted to be an actor no
oh i'm pretty shy actually shocking
yeah shockingly a bit shy and uh
i i you know some people just have that
skill i i've had too many concussions to
remember things you know so lines
lines would struggle me a bit you know
what i mean because i i
don't remember as well as i used to um
and what did you see as a kid that said
i want to do that like i remember seeing
you know freddie prinze or whatever and
i said oh that's that's kind of what i
want to do like what was your first like
oh [ __ ] that
that moment cooper right on yeah
of course yeah yeah my brother's uh
you know i'm the youngest of five so my
older brothers were always you know they
were always the cool one and i was the
secondary guy like
i was uh skee you know when my older
brother i'm sonny hooper
you're a ski yeah the sidekick i'm
always the side class you know of course
and uh yeah it was there's always that
with older brothers
and um so i i just i pursued it you know
i i
didn't know how to go about it and i got
a job through my brother's girlfriend
at the time uh just to be a pa on a
commercial
and i networked i just kept asking how
do i how do i become a stunt man how do
i become a stunt man you know everyone
wanted to be cult savers you know what i
mean
of course i did martial arts growing up
so i figured uh this is a good
transition
i'm too short in films that you never
see me fighting really because
you don't want the little guy fighting
the big you know that you get an actor
beating up the little guy it's not
really that but you're you're
you're almost like you're a specialist
because you do the
you do some really tough stunts yeah
i've been given the ones where
basically they're like well someone's
gonna get jacked up and my whole
my whole thing basically was i get up no
matter what i've broken things
i'll get up i'll get up and i'll do it
again i broke my ankle i duct taped it
and we finished that day even when i
blew up my knees
you know you just you wrap them up and
you keep going oh that's that's
that is a different we were talking just
before we walked in i said
well i'm sure a lot of people have no
problem doing it once
but after you get your ass kicked you
gotta do it again what about my fat ass
if i put some [ __ ]
mustard on my shirt i'd go home and not
come back this dude's like [ __ ]
wrapping his [ __ ] knee and i'm like
oh man
[ __ ] ketchup on my shirt [ __ ] you
guys i
that's a wrap and then what's the first
uh what's what was the first hunch you
did
first stunt was you know the the first
ones you kind of end up doing for free
right they i i did uh jeez it was in the
the
i used to pa on rap videos and i was
still trying to you know hustle and the
stunt coordinator julius lafleur
i just kept asking hey man how do i how
do i become a stunt guy and he's like
well you know we'll let you do some
stuff
so he put me and i got the hookup
masterpiece film
uh back in late 90s i think it was wow
and i was passenger in the car with
corey eubanks who's a great stunt man
he was a luke duke or a uh luke duke
double
in the dukes of hazard david oh right on
so the guy's an incredible driver yeah
and just a really good guy yeah corey
eubank's his dad's bob eubanks
oh my god yeah bob eubanks promoted the
first beatles concert at the hollywood
bowl
i didn't know i was about to say that
i'm a huge fan of fans oh i just bought
you
yeah lennon was my hero that's
everything let me go about that later on
what about what about when p
diddy and um they did i'll be watching
you the biggie thing and he was riding
the motorcycle oh he crashed and he
crashed was that really him oh yeah
oh man oh yeah he was goofing off and
the bike got away from him and he just
tried to ride it out as his fishtailing
and
he smacked the ground hard they stopped
production for a few hours
and you know he did it again he got back
up on it so to his credit you know he
got back up on it but yeah it did shook
him up
and what was your first time uh let me
see what was my actual first stunt they
threw me down some
or somewhere close to it yeah they they
i had to do
some metal stairs oh wow and it was
it was a long way down and there was a
plot you know just a flat landing
in the middle of it and i had to hop hit
and hop over that landing to continue
the stair fall
and then land flat right before camera
that was right in front of me on the
ground
and not hit camera i'm like why i'm
flopping down some stairs i don't really
have that breaks yeah
i it landed perfectly it was all right
yeah it made me a hero for the day
right yeah oh yeah and then you didn't
get hurt at all right no
you know the stairs you're sore yeah
not hurt enough to go home and then bill
hammond who's cedric's friend and
anthony's friend
he was gonna get married he was walking
down some stairs and he tripped and
broke his leg and his [ __ ] hip
femur
walking down the aisle your [ __ ]
compound fracture
who drove me to the church tiger okay
still make it all right let's go to some
stories
all right uh so what we do here uh our
guest is
you know i i i want to
allow frosty what we're doing frosty
silver's our guest and what we do here
is we do actual news and these are crazy
news stories that we kind of wish
weren't real news stories
and they aren't and this is our first
one this is what really happened
i didn't realize you were such a [ __ ]
novice eh in the world of entertainment
surprise that's me
all right you're out of the secretarial
pool you couldn't even [ __ ] type
that's right we're going to stunts all
right let's get to let's go all right
our first one
is uh outstanding uh this one's from
folks paper
a man sues a kentucky hospital for 1.2
million dollars
after doctors performed a c-section on
him by mistake
a c-section on a man a louisville man
called 9-1-1 after he thought he had
signs of a heart attack
at a kentucky hospital and doctors
performed a c-section on him by mistake
he was a clinically obese man with a
history of heart attacks you know
sometimes
the clinically obese people like their
penis
you can't see it like his pedal was
probably out
and he had you know the gut and he and
his and his pubes were there he probably
spread bread right there you couldn't
see anything in there
and uh you know spread bread
and you know a lot of you know a lot of
older ladies are trying to have babies
so
he probably had that [ __ ] up hair and
he's laying down there with a big
looking boiler with a lot of pubes and
they're like
you know we got to get this kid out it's
probably got a biblical core wrapper on
his neck
yeah his his quote is just so
outstanding he says
did my genitalia go unnoticed
your point exactly that's what the man
said oh yeah they finally finally got it
with your [ __ ] sir
[Laughter]
i'm kind of happy that she's talking to
the hospital [ __ ] tell everybody
you can hear you down the whole [ __ ]
hall big [ __ ] small penis
one of the two which one you want it's
clipped here yeah he's a
an f7 other than the seven so so
yeah so they did a c-section but when
they opened it up what did they what did
they find
they said uh the doctors tried to get 34
year old man of cesarean delivery and
finally found that he was not pregnant
and had no uterus
that's what it says he's screaming pain
like my thea and they asked me if i
wanted anything
george they took my box out
come on look at that where were
my eggs they're in the refrigerator
don't eat them huh
all right okay next story ah yes that's
outstanding i mean i had meniscus
surgery which i'm sure frost you've had
a lot of surgeries do they make you
right on your leg
this is the right leg to operate on
that's what they do now
i i did i know but i i just had my foot
fixed uh
at the start of the year and i had a
broken toe for
about four years that i just dealt with
and they had to put i had to put four
four pins two plates rotate the bone
over and this was just at the start of
january
uh so i'm not supposed to really be in a
boot and walking around with oh
why'd you break your ankle uh you know
it was uh
on venom doing some rehearsals well it
was already broken from
other injuries but i was still working
and
it was in the scene where venom's
learning how to use his uh he's becoming
venom
so hardy comes out the window
three-story window drop so i jump out
the window as i'm dropping it's on
rehearsals
he kind of uses his arm to swing himself
over this balcony
and as i'm going the the gag is as i
swing over the balcony
i jump over the railing and then hit
this glass and go through the glass
but at first they wanted me to wreck on
the balcony so i would just tumble no
problem
and that's just some guy on a quick
release basically as my line gets over
he releases me so i can drop
otherwise i'm just going to swing high
and into everything so this guy
said he dropped me early so i stabbed
into the
railing of the balcony and it bent the
top of my foot
flat to my shin and
yeah you have about two hours
two to three hours before you really
start feeling that really badly so if
you need to you can get those rehearsals
done quickly that's
incredible man unbelievable and
then you shake it off right it took you
months to even
deal with it yeah you just worked with
it yeah yeah you just yeah it just hurt
for a little bit and you deal with it
yeah
is that because um well i guess
if you look back at the beginning of of
movies if somebody got hurt
they kind of had to do it again unless
you get fired if you're not gonna do it
again
yeah so then from that from the
inception
if you hurt yourself you you do it again
so so then you get the reputation of
being
really durable but in reality and
reliable and in reality
every every day you wake up you're in
pain yeah i've never missed a day at
work
and i got impaled 20 feet in the air on
the last indiana jones on a rehearsal
um 12 17
17 stitches 12 staples i show up to work
the next day i'm like
guys oh my god you're not supposed to be
here are you
yeah i guess i am that's
i mean this dude is phenomenal so if
you're hurt okay say you got stitches so
nine times out of ten when you do
another stunt you're gonna blow those
stitches right yeah that's one of the
reasons
staples oh okay yeah mr [ __ ] nine
times out of ten over here
i had to see something i had sort of a
c-section story
similar to that but that's later
okay i mean all of it and yeah
all that stuff is just amazing to me
because who doesn't want to be in the
glory like
you know either a daredevil or
you know you try to jump off your house
into the pool
and now with instagram you see really
all those times that people miss
you know or people that are drunk trying
to do stuff oh yeah right
busting out those they're trying to jump
on tables and [ __ ] yeah
i mean people are more talented than
they ever were right now all the free
runner kids all the guys doing all the
tricking and stuff
yeah problem with the new young stunt
guys they don't like to hit the ground
they're afraid of the ground oh wow yeah
yeah interesting so yeah you got to kind
of
they go to the old guys will you do that
yeah of course it's my job
okay all right what's the next one all
right this is one of the smartest
criminals ever this was from cbs
pittsburgh a westmoreland county man is
facing multiple charges after
police say he falsely reported his
vehicle as stolen then set on fire
man falsely reports his vehicle is
stolen and then google's actually they
found on his google
history how to set your car on fire and
make it look like an accident
geniuses so this poor guy he wanted to
get a deal on his car right so
what they did is what did he get a deal
on it why would he lie he was behind him
payments or for insurance
because earlier this month state police
said 54 year old donald cassidy of west
newton reported his vehicles as stolen
a few days later the vehicle was found
and uh it had been set on fire uh beyond
recognition
so the only way they could tell was his
car is through the vin number then
they after taking his phone and
executing a search warrant police say
a look through his google history turned
up the search how to set your car
on fire and make it look like an
accident
you would think you just think damn it
but you know people are so stupid that
they think like
they say hey give me your phone it's
locked like you're going to get away
with that
but they they do all of that recon
like i follow the guy chris watts the
guy in colorado that
you know um killed his wife
and his kids and he was dating some girl
at work
and when it went down she deleted
all of her text from him and all the
pictures from him
and the cop said you know why would you
do that and she was like well you know
he lied to me
and i was like i don't want anything to
do
with this guy anymore but in reality she
destroyed evidence
and then they were trying to get still
get the text from her
and when she walked in the first time
she goes i'm not in trouble am i because
i deleted all that stuff and
really it's obstruction of justice
absolutely and she walked
and she just yeah disappeared she got
away with it though i mean no no
she's still walking around when when i
had a situation with somebody that was
uh kind of stalking me
and i had the messages and i told i
called the fbi and i said hey i got this
person bothering me i
had a case on some other people and they
said well bring in your phone
and we'll do a dump we'll dump it we'll
dump all of the
messages that you have your whole
history and then i said
you know we don't have to do that
the kid born with three oils down there
like a food court the only thing they
didn't have down there with a panda
[Laughter]
beautiful there's some wild things okay
so
if you try to if you try to like me like
you know allegedly have a neighbor that
has some trees that
are bothersome and i've looked up how to
kill a tree without anybody knowing so
you know and plus i just said it you
know there's just a few million people
listening yeah they have an
ill tree you know you know people have
been
you know they've they poison trees and
then you could
you could i mean i i wouldn't but people
poison animals if they did like that so
back then you wouldn't know you give a
dog a grape you know you'll die
but it's shocking and now you know that
if a dog died that
the person would do the autopsy
and then they find one of these in his
coulomb oh my god
[Laughter]
i'm hungry you do not have coven
yeah so you can't you can't uh we tested
you can't be
you can't be slick with all that stuff
like i guess i could say it now i've had
two phones for a long time and you know
people say why do you have two phones
well you know i'm a writer and a
producer
but really i was to keep you know
things separate better not for everybody
i mean i remember i remember
years ago there was a comedian on stage
and he was talking about
that sometimes guys have two phones and
he was out there doing it and after the
second night
every comedian pulled him aside and go
come over here man drop that [ __ ] bit
right there
tonight don't ever [ __ ] do it again
how come it goes because you know
there's people out there man there's
guys out there have two phones that may
have a situation with a wife that
they're
on the fringe and you say that the wife
looks at him his wife's like give me
give me your phones and unlock them
instantly
and you're in trouble yeah right because
if you look for something
you'll find it i mean i'm sure there's
fat people that have cakes and sugar
it's relative you know like i would have
chonchos and panocha
and all that but somebody who's obese
would have like you know some
eclairs you know that [ __ ] entamons and
you know
that's their porn you know
a [ __ ] guy you know walking with a
[ __ ] pizza oh there's another table
oh my god okay the
all right well here's one after my own
heart have you been tested for covid
yes i have yeah you've gotten your shots
i've got no no i haven't gotten the
shots i've gotten tested so i've gotten
the i've been testing the nose
oh you're good yeah yeah yeah i've
gotten them you got the shots
no no oh the test that's just yeah when
i did uh
the film i did last year they would go
into your nose
out your nose and they'd tickle the back
of your brain and that same one would go
in your throat
right oh what that was the only time
that whole entire film we did that and
i've never done it since that way but
that's like porn ass to mouth
exactly you can't go on the nose yeah
a little chapstick on the edge of that
thing like you do astro mouth you're
like ah
that's so nice that's why i do george
[Laughter]
you just want to make out for a bit
right i wonder what they called it
it's cool it was cool i call it like
surf and turf that we need
[Laughter]
my [ __ ] wiener schnitzel over there
okay
uh here's our next one uh
journaltimes.com one time when we were
little kids there was a
uh uh a used kotek
in the ho in the alley you know
sometimes i tr they throw the trash away
and the kotec
fell out of the trash and it was a long
one with the two little straps right
there yeah
things you know and it was and the word
spread through the neighborhood so
every boy who had a bike was over there
in the summer
looking at this kotec riding circles
around it like looking at it
and then after like three days we
finally got the nerve to turn it over
to see if it was used
[Laughter]
and then we got this little kid daryl to
use it as a headband and
he was a little chamberlain okay what's
the next one oh my god
that was a dude that honked when he
talked hey you kids you talked you got
daryl vaughn ugh i've never met this kid
but i've been imitating for him for
about 15 years
you can't not do it after george does
every time you see kids hey your kid huh
and i've never seen the kid
poor dairy did you say it after every
sentence i had a joke where i were my
mom was making a sandwich and she bent
over you could see the string and i
pulled out
oh and she's like remember that was
chasing me around with a microphone and
then you would
run around
[Laughter]
how to celebrate your independence with
some with some [ __ ]
what was the long one i got going m-80s
m-80s yeah yeah the old m80s
all right but um yeah what was that last
story i forgot
already this [ __ ]
i'm already i feel uh i'm thank god i
didn't drive
yeah i did not drive today
get out you know the car you hit
somebody's house and you get out cut
check the gate just because there's a
[ __ ] move here just leave it check
the gate check the gate
justice plan pretend that you know
beautiful well uh uh your your uh friend
steve i
held a guitar cord so long that he had
to undergo surgery
a professional guitarist he was working
on it so hard yep i know you ever missed
everybody no i've never met him but i
know of them yeah
sure yeah he said he won't be playing
for a while following his recent trigger
figure
finger surgery which he attributes to
holding a tricky chord for too long
listen i love steve vibe but
you know demo look i said i won't be
playing for a while like people are
waiting
oh my goodness i mean i love him he's a
beautiful individual
and you've had it you've talked to him
before you like you had to make it worse
but you know you had a conversation with
him before i did
yeah he played that you know he's an
incredibly talented guitar player
ralph listen if you believe ralph
macchio could beat him and cross
crossroads come on man
that's acting [ __ ] wrong so rough
macho beats steve bai
and then in karate kid that's the
[ __ ] lady thighs and he
kicks that dude's ass he beats up johnny
johnny would have kicked his ass in real
life i'd have to believe i think yeah
but steve i saw he held a note
i don't i don't know about that one man
i don't know about that one
because i mean how long do you hold the
note just until
he said it was tricking he said it was
his thumb was reaching over
so he held it too long and you know what
trigger finger is you probably know what
it is
it's when your finger actually gets
stuck oh yeah bent and then it kind of
just goes
straight or way bent a lot of guitar
players
might get that too yeah i think i got
the double jointed thing you got
everything going on yeah i got a lot of
breakfast oh my god you know what the
frosty could have [ __ ] been houdini
in another life
this [ __ ] shoulder didn't come
out you know you can put it you know he
can take his [ __ ] leg off and give it
to you and then after the podcast hey
bro
i'm going with you know i'm headed out
to studio city do you mind if i have my
[ __ ] leg back
like this dude has been in so much pain
this is true and what type of women do
do you do you you remember
i have been married yeah yeah i just
recently divorced yeah
but we're still good friends i mean yeah
she's still well that's cool yeah
absolutely
i hate when people [ __ ] say that
we're still good friends well it's a
different we didn't get divorced for
like your normal reasons i became
i kind of was i went through a thing and
i became a bit of an [ __ ] so oh wow
she just got tired of me oh that
yeah [ __ ] if that was making you a male
if that was grounds for divorce nobody
[ __ ] be married i can't say
they [ __ ] noah's ark fight two people
[ __ ] it together
i went through this thing as a little
bit of an [ __ ]
i just swore but you know oh okay all
right so
so frosty if he swears he's how many
push-ups five
five but anywhere i am and he's doing
them like nothing
yeah he did the old he does the old foot
cross
like i'm a professional push-up guy oh
no i have a broken toe oh well there's
that yeah
so i have to how great is that so when i
when i
this is here's a good i don't gotta tell
this one so when rocky came out
rocky back in the day you're too young
frog so rocky came out
and everybody went to go see it and
i was in 10th grade and my
i went with my grandparents to her to
drive in my grandparents will see rocky
very familiar i'm in 10th grade with my
grandparents my grandmother and
grandfather fall asleep in the front
seat
and i'm watching rocky from the back
seat and i go to the snack bar and they
have a t-shirt that has rocky with a
thing like a black t-shirt
so they let me drive home from support
water which is all the way down to
public to mission hills probably like 10
miles
so they're in the back both asleep you
know
immigrants in the back there um
slept longer so all right we're here
we're in l.a to get out i
so i was in class with it with these
seniors
in high school and they see me like at
12 30 in a riviera on sepulveda at a
light by myself and i look over
and it's the people in my class but
they're seniors so they look at me and
they're looking at me like is this
[ __ ] 10th grade [ __ ]
at 12 30 at riviera by himself my
grandparents were asleep in the back
it made me look i was the coolest spot
right but little they know your car
so everybody wanted to be rocky so i
started to run in the morning and play
the song
so i drank i cracked a couple of eggs
raw eggs yeah i put them in a jar and
when i drank them that [ __ ] yellow
[ __ ]
shot out of my trap like [ __ ] all
over oh my god
like i don't know what that was about
but
if you ever drink raw egg i don't i did
it just uh just
just because i said yeah yeah because
everybody gave it a shot yeah
it's grotesque oh i think they say it's
the protein right you get the
i don't know now i feel bad for all the
ladies of the
grace with spy like okay so what's the
next one
charlotte ladies and gentlemen styling
oh um
i i uh okay here we go but man this [ __ ]
has got a brother
this thing took a hold of me frost you
picked the wrong time to be right now
bless america this stuff is not kidding
around
oh i was in debate of giving myself an
excuse like it was
you gave up so much other [ __ ] i mean
stuff yeah
i'd be doing push-ups maybe you could
just like you know give yourself a day
off
all right here's what speaking of that
uh the journaltimes.com reports that
three drunk drivers
all crashed into each other in mount
pleasant after
that's in uh that is mount pleasant
wisconsin well at least they found each
other
three cars driven by drunk drivers
crashed into each other at an
intersection on highway 11 and 32 in
mount pleasant
wisconsin early sunday morning uh all
three men have been arrested
and at least one whose sav ended up
being fully engulfed in fire was treated
at the hospital
so uh but has that ever happened before
i've never heard of that drunk dudes
have had to have run into each other but
it's
all three everybody involved and one guy
left
one dude uh last call
well i i wouldn't read this but ask that
guy because this car drivable
his whole [ __ ] front end that's
almost like they said tiger you think
you could drive yourself to cedars
[ __ ] i've rolled ten times down
this hill
oh my god i never thought remember the
hiring patrol told that guy we got hit
last
friday yeah we got an accident last
friday yeah and and the car just
fell his car fell apart and the cops
said is it drivable
they start it up and every ship flies
everywhere
there was no way this guy and he was
going to make this a little 19 year old
white kid i thought i hit the [ __ ]
katie lange
i thought it looked like katie lange
he's all give it a try
he said 510 on his license [ __ ] is 74
pounds
a [ __ ] knife oh boy he was a rails 44
i felt so sorry and then think of it
that you rear-end some when you feel bad
enough and then george lopez walks like
ah [ __ ] this guy's gonna make it this is
gonna be bad
but i think he knew it was made oh yeah
at first he didn't realize that then
afterwards he did
and you know it was george was crazy
cool with the guy so
yeah yeah yeah so anyway so what
happened was this is
one guy was drunk and another guy was
drunk and they're going opposite ways on
i would read this but i can't um they're
going opposite ways on the highway and
one guy swerves out of his lane so they
go head on don't try to read
this here but you know don't don't yeah
drinking and driving is
is is pretty bad that that's the one
thing that
um you don't want to do and too many
people do
too many people do it is yeah right you
don't want to lose somebody
and nowadays you can there's so many
ways yeah yeah
it's yeah it's too easy and latinos you
know that's how they if you tell them
like if we're going out drinking all
three of us you have a latina and she'll
be like hey
if you [ __ ] drink too much don't be
calling a [ __ ] uber put that [ __ ] on
my card
take the [ __ ] back streets like a
real [ __ ] man pee a man and drive
drunk
you go to a concert at the forum it
takes you [ __ ] three weeks to get
back to that [ __ ] encino
he says a ford f250 pickup truck was
heading southbound on highway 32 it
drifted into the northbound lane
heading straight for a gmc yukon suv the
driver of the uconn attempted to swerve
to avoid the oncoming pickup
but was still hit head-on moments later
a chevrolet equinox driving northbound
on that we already hit the pickup truck
so these guys went ahead on and then
this guy runs into both of them
and and the guy the dude i think the
third dude was
did it he was like he took his
[Laughter]
was he the guy that ran off the guy who
ran off was the guy who got
hit the second time he got rear-ended to
say and he just
boned out because i think that was his
third his third as they
say o.w.i hear walter cronkite say
and in vietnam on the ho chi minh trail
americans boned out they deboned
hey walter cronkite that is the news it
said the drivers of the
ford f-250 and the chevy equinox
remained on the scene but both showed
signs of impairment and were arrested on
suspicion of owi
operating while influenced what happened
to the guy with his truck burning down
is that an old w
that's a dude iran that's the guy who
took off yeah
did he just leave his truck there he
just left oh they got him oh they got
him later because that was his uh
third third uh third dui
that's not a good way to go yeah that's
right not like that
no well i mean you know then you flee
the scene i mean he hit me he hit two
cars that just crashed did you know this
but you know as as easy as it is to not
drive while you're impaired a lot of
people still do it
right yes they still do it yes yeah
it happens all the time every single day
i mean you think you have a couple beers
and you think you're okay one time i
went to see mark anthony at the
universal amphitheater
another black porsche i have all black
and i went over there and i went out
there on stage with them and i was
drinking tequila with them and some
coors lights and i really
lived very close to the amphitheater so
i took a turn
on kawenga and i'm going on koenga
highway patrolman
gets off hits the lights right by carl's
jr right there in kawinga
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm not hammered
but i've been drinking
black porsche all black i rolled the
window down the cop looks in
recognizes me and he says oh i'm sorry
have a good night and he [ __ ] drove
off and i'm like man
i yelled at him i'm [ __ ] up come back
i couldn't believe it i could have gone
home just never put it in gear just in
neutral all the way
ah he let me go that's a blessing that
way isn't it man
i had i had a little story i'll say
really but uh
when i saw brian i went to a bachelor
party my friend ernie would always get
mad
when we made fun we would always make
fun of his mom
and uh on balboa we went to a bachelor
party when we were 19
and they had a porno that they were
showing on the wall like a sheet on the
wall like a stag film
and they show a lady that was fingering
herself with all these pedals that i
said
i said to them as everybody all the guys
are watching i go so what ernie your mom
can't find her keys
and he [ __ ] took off he took off and
he left me there
and i had to walk home like four miles
all the way down
and the dudes laughed so hard so hey
erin your mom can't fight it
so anything so so i forgot this one at
alcatraz me guillermo and ernie went to
alcatraz
when my gran my mom was in sacramento
and over there they weren't all contrast
so from the from the a parking lot
there's a guy with like the
smokey the bear hat and park services
he's talking about alcatraz
and alcatraz called the rock you know
these three guys may have
may have escaped nobody's sure he goes
and then you know
babyface nelson and al capone
and the birdman of alcatraz have been
there and then he goes through all the
criminals and then he says any questions
and then my friend guillermo holds his
hand up he goes
yes sir he goes was that that criminal
n a there and he said i'm sorry he goes
n a was a gangster n a
and he goes uh no i don't think
n a was there and then ernie goes what's
n a he goes nipple ariana that's his
last name
left us again oh gosh well that's the
actual news
uh yeah the word well now we get
actually uh this this is a great portion
of the show where we get to listen to
actual voicemails
right we gotta put our headphones on to
listen to them but these are actual
listeners of the show and they ask
questions of george and are were you too
and if exactly and if you guys want to
call in and ask george a question or
some advice it's eight one eight five
three three one eight four three
so here we go and then if you were going
to ask me for advice what would it be
because we've known each other a long
time for advice
i would ask you um
if you're thinking about getting married
you have the greatest advice about
giving me
he really i didn't listen to it if you
think about getting married i didn't
listen
what is your first impression of someone
said who says
we're engaged to be married what's the
first thing you that comes to your mind
um was mine yeah [ __ ] misery
somebody said to me i said to somebody
you ever seen somebody get killed you
ever see somebody die
and they said i never have i said i did
you did yep
i was staying in hawaii um at the four
seasons and i had a
balcony that overlooked the water and i
saw a guy walking down and
he walked up to a bunch of people and
then
there was a woman there and they like
exchanged rings and then after that
nobody saw him
he'd come forever all his friends never
saw him yeah
i told george i was i was in love and he
just told me like don't whatever prop
whatever problems you have
whatever problems you have when you're
dating which everybody has problems
people still go down the path
um and you think you're either going to
correct it
you're like evil knievel in the air i
can just do this no
you think you can correct it once you
get in the relationship but
it doesn't become easier it's always
hard
and i think in business in your business
i don't know what your wife did or
but when you have to be away or when we
have to be away
what i i don't want to say but when a
guy works during the day
and he leaves at 7 45 and he's back at 4
15 every day
you can expect a certain amount of
responsibility
from that guy but you might be home a
month i might be home a month you might
be home month
but when we go our hours don't
adhere to any regular schedule but yet
women
hold us accountable as if we had jobs
that
didn't have emotion or pain or pressure
and you can just roll in home and then
just
integrate yourself into and it's that's
not it yeah and we don't get credit for
that like you know i have a dark side
when i was dating ann she knew i had a
dark side and yet when we got married
she wanted the dark side to go away
it didn't go away it just got darker
mm-hmm it's party i mean it's partying
right it really kind of is what
drives people isolation
and you know because anybody who's
really talented i mean
listen frosty like what kid grows up and
says you know i want to do something
where i [ __ ] bust my ankle and it's
almost touching my shin
i mean nobody so there's something of
attentive
attention but i think in in your
business
where only the failures get recognized
and not the successes
a lot of the time sadly yeah and you
just become a reliable
person you know like a reliable that he
can do this and walk away
but yet like he's busted up
and even if you don't walk away
necessarily the production never heard
about it
and that's that's where they are happy
with you you know because
i'd never say i'm hurt no matter what
you don't want to ruffle anybody's
i just yeah i don't get it well you
don't want to have that reputation as a
stunt guy oh that guy is always
broken right we can't use him he's
broken again even if i'm broken i can
still outperform a lot of people so
i'll just keep going and not by talent i
mean they're usually a lot more talented
than me i just have a lot more heart
yeah a couple more balls what about
those pluto that try to go over niagara
falls in a [ __ ] barrel like
[ __ ] there's no do you think there's
any [ __ ] training to that
huh get in this pabst blue ribbon keg
and we'll see you at the [ __ ] outlet
ball down there
you wash up on shore right that's [ __ ]
that's crazy
you just go for it just get the bounce i
think there's suicidal people that do
that one
i think they're always like well if it
doesn't make it i kind of achieved my
thing anyway right
and if i make it i'm a hero yeah yeah
have you been white white water rafting
oh yeah i've been uh yeah a few times no
i wouldn't go white water rafting
because i'm afraid that
you know i would drown or hit my head on
a rock oh you know you see a little
six weeks later they find a little
paleto
[Laughter]
the lazy river oh yeah that's just all
all urine
here and now the hepatitis group you're
next
it's like the philippines yeah you touch
the water rub your eye you're [ __ ]
blind in that eye
[Laughter]
okay let's let's let's let's do a
voicemail or two shall we
right oh we got it we gotta put our
headphones on we've got today oh okay
all right let me get this okay
frosty plays too i know damn boss you
got to play a little bit
sure here you you uh hang out of mine
and i'll let you guys
start warming up then i and you have to
give me another
sentence so i could write another song
on the fly
was that what you guys do i did a lot
did that do it last week which one was
it what did it yeah
he has these three chords
i like that you carry guitar picks with
you
oh all right something
[Music]
[Laughter]
richard o'toole over here he's all
[ __ ] up
yeah one beer is gone seriously man you
guys look fantastic with those guitars
so envious that i'm not having beer with
you i'm sorry i'm gonna do five push-ups
phil what's your favorite girl sales and
crumb cream crocks
shields and crocks oh [ __ ] okay i gotta
get my
my headphones and i keep forgetting okay
is everybody in
all right frosty needs to let's oh you
need your uh you gotta have your things
on
no hey that guy
give me give me a second i think i could
write a song um everybody leave me alone
everybody leave me alone oh wait wait
get
here
all right
i'll just follow him yeah yeah pulling
on my bone and my tea i
walk it i let the air
[Music]
leave yellow okay let's go through some
voicemails
uh and grant grant our engineering
producer is gonna throw this one right
now
how did you start playing guitar frosty
uh my rehab
my
my older brothers are always in bands so
brother dante he's an amazing drummer
let's hear you play a little bit
uh
[Music]
it's a g beautiful g and a beautiful d
beatles man oh here's this one
it's a little norwegian wood yeah with
it with the face he
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh yeah i get nervous now
you're fine you're fine you know a
little beetles that's cool
that's a fast version of um
[Music]
uh live forever go well done well
man this is done i'm like it's like a
concert for me
[Music]
my my mine fell over i'm on my second
one are you
yeah might i might may i yeah because
since frosty's not i can't
i wish i'm taking the train i love this
one
from gordon lightfoot if you could eat
my coulomb
what a tail my tail would tell
just like some calzones
that you found in a wishing well okay
that's it
all right let's go to the carson castle
this is my favorite if you could eat my
cookie okay here we go for here's our
first one
gotta let you know i'm 38 years old
coming from albuquerque new mexico senor
and every day before i go to work
i watch your show syndicated on pbs it's
a pleasure to enjoy
the laughter the comedy and also the
real life experiences
that us chicanos mexicans latinos
hispanics endure
every day
i mean i love everything that you do
brother so thank you very much
and god bless you and everything you do
oh my goodness
it wasn't a question was it you know
what that's very nice listen uh
you know latinos don't have a lot of you
know people to be proud of
[Laughter]
my parents will be happy to hear that
yeah
so albuquerque yes we're doing a lot of
movies in albuquerque and all that stuff
so
it's uh it's a great
the great state of uh you've been you've
done what stunts have you done in
albuquerque
i did gamer uh with uh gerard butler did
that film there
uh two guns what was that stunt do you
remember uh i was assistant
uh stunt coordinator but i did a bit of
everything i broke my shoulder in it
oh good you know what has a as a
coordinator has a stuntman ever said you
know
i don't think i don't think i'm feeling
this thing uh
yeah it's shocking to me i've never said
no and i don't understand
when a person they know what they're
getting into like it's not just
thrown at them on the day you know we
rehearse these things and
then suddenly on on the day they're like
i'm not sure if i can do that
what happened to the two weeks we had
you on right probably said it then
hey do you know my stuntman eddie what's
his name eddie eddie fernandez eddie
ferdinand so
eddie fernandez we did an episode of my
show where i was putting in a
a fan in my mom's bathroom and i fall
back
and fall in the bathtub which i never
thought i would do it i said i would but
then eddie showed up and he kind of
looks like me and put on the same
clothes so he's been my guy for
like 18 17 18 years yeah he's a great
guy
and he did a thing in the johnny depp
movie where you know about that one
where he played where johnny depp was
the indian guy was what was that oh uh
lone ranger lone ranger so he got
he got thrown out of a moving train
do you remember that yeah yeah yeah and
the camera bumped on the rail and they
had to do it again and eddie said
that he did it again but he didn't
remember doing it again
just dangerous man like he's he's he
said yeah
i did it twice but i didn't i have no
recollection of
the second one at all and you know the
director would be like let's go again
real
real quick and you have no recollection
that's
pretty dangerous that's a pretty
dangerous thing to do yeah to somebody
and not check if somebody's
you know are you all right and you know
yeah but what would frosty say yeah i'm
fine
yeah thumbs up jacked up right yeah dude
yeah it's crazy to me
i did a thing on gamer and i flew out of
a hole and i landed on i
flew 25 feet through the air spinning
and it was a last-minute thing they're
like well can we
put a big explosion when you first leave
and i'm like well that's my face oh i'm
not the best looking guy but i kind of
like my face
and so i put a fire hood on so now i
can't see where i'm landing
and i missed my landing bit
smacked onto cement 25 feet away
shattered my rib
and i remember i had to get up and the
the guys are like you're all right i'm
like
i can't breathe but yeah oh man
i mean what what what kind of um
what kind of what kind of job is that
like
like i mean i'm sure it's you know like
and nobody knows it's you they they
think it's you know
[ __ ] gerard de pardue all right like
that part where you did that backflip
was fantastic to gerard and you get
you know
[Laughter]
hi george my name is patrick from san
jose california and i want your advice
on how to deal with
internet trolls online
that dude sounds like a guy that's going
from house to house tickling kulos
[Laughter]
huh i'm not exactly sure what a mamon
means they're going to find a lot of
chicken bones in his trunk
uh my mom is like a suck-up i'm so sorry
i just think internet trolls right you
don't pay don't pay attention
but that guy's not a guy who's known so
i don't know what trolls he would have
it's not like when somebody's known and
they're just doing it for
you know because it's anonymous which is
and they want a celebrity to go to write
them back or to block you like a lot of
people
yeah a lot of those kids just want to
get blocked
so one time a kid says hey george can i
ask you a question and i put
nine i send nine back and they go what's
that
i said dicks your mom can fit in her
mouth
so you say you're uh you're you're
observing the lenten holiday
are you yeah no because you know hey man
get them or they'll get you
yeah well done oh
god all right all right uh next yeah
let's go next
[Music]
hi george my name is rose and i'm from
the south banana valley
and i just wanted to know how did you
become
el mas like that's my my one of my
biggest
questions i wanted to ask you all right
have a nice day
bye ah well you know i'm from the san
francisco i
i just think how does anybody become
you know you were in the clubs i mean we
i knew we met when
there really wasn't anything going on
yeah i mean you're king of the clubs i
mean you're
you're killing but you were not i mean
tv star at that time but you're
you're crushing it in the clubs so you
have to you have to work
while other people are sleeping in order
to be good at something
being hispanic because you have to work
harder you think yeah
yeah it's worth it or i mean obviously
the work ethic is huge
well there's that never sits yeah
there's not a lot of
that's it isn't it though that's the
success part where people just expect it
to fall in their lap
that doesn't happen very often you know
no
yeah there's no that whole lucky thing
is like nobody gets
you know nobody lasts 20 years and
gets lucky so i mean whatever i mean you
know what it comes
internet trolls i think would just say
it comes with the territory
and when was the first time uh the name
was thrown around el masjin gone oh
that's good
um i
maybe in the last like 2012 i think
yeah some room yeah because we got gone
in the
2006 seven we didn't really use chin
going on the talk show i think my stream
going came after like 12
14. almost a tv land show that lopez
show okay
yeah you've had a few shows actually too
the late night one was so fun the late
night was such a fun show it was fun
they're all fun yeah yes
you could imagine kobe kobe
came on and kobe didn't do anything once
once the
season started and
um just great moments man like john
popper you know blues traveler
oh yeah he was there and he he was on
and then afterwards
he comes into the green room he's got
that vest with all the harmonicas and i
said hey
are you the greatest harmonica player in
the world he goes yes i am
and he pulls one out and plays and gives
it to me i still have it
and then we were drinking shots of
tequila and then i drove i rolled
i pulled i had to go over kawenga into
hollywood i lived on nichols canyon
and i drove where the hollywood bowl
goes on kawang i made it right
i thought i was going up my street it
actually ended up in the [ __ ]
hollywood bowl
oh my god all right i said ah
i almost broke my neck
oh man that's it i don't do that anymore
all right and then i would always see
the dude that was jesus remember that
guy
the jesus guy that was walking in the
middle of the night with the robe and
the sandals
he passed a few years ago in hollywood
he was a guy that was like jesus
i like to walk up hollywood boulevard
right i used to live right by the
hollywood bowl too i'm kind of trying to
remember that guy it was a guy that was
he's famous in videos he had the shroud
a beard long hairy sandals and we go
jesus and we waited wait the [ __ ] with
jesus that guy dennis mckinnon or some
dennis something
that got you that car yeah yeah yeah
it was always like his resume on his car
that guy was around forever
and then the dude that played superman
passed away yeah and then
on the on the talk show he didn't have
any teeth in the front and we were going
to
get a dentist to give him teeth and then
we were videotaping him he went on this
racist
rant and we pulled his teeth
so he took him right back [ __ ] you i
took those teeth right back
you're gonna kiss that [ __ ] bicuspid
goodbyes [ __ ] superman
right you could have black ones you just
can't have white ones you're racist
[Music]
hey we're back and we were with uh
frosty silva the greatest
he really is in the world yeah he's you
know if i felt uncomfortable
with maybe doing a show somewhere i knew
i maybe wasn't a drawer so i could say
you know i'ma pass
but frosty's in a business where if you
pass a quest
they question your heart question your
integrity your courage if you go
i don't know absolutely they don't allow
you it's not really allowed
well it's weird the new the new stunt
guys
they they will say no but they they're
they're put in a position where they
shouldn't have been doing that gag
anyway you know what i mean they're
they're the great free
they're the great guys could do all
these tricks but you know what i think i
think you know you
when you said you started as a pa and
all that and then you end up doing
these amazing stunts but
you know a lot of people might not have
gone down that that road they might have
said oh
you know i'm gonna do a pa and i'll do
i'll drive a little bit but i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna do that and you were all
in huh i wanted to be a stuntman that's
all i wanted to do
and and i knew it like i had i had my
days to join the guild
to be an ad i could have gone art i was
doing every other department just to
just to work you know just pay my rent
and uh
yeah i just kept working i i wanted to
be a stunt man so i turned everything
down i finally got a
i did a commercial and it earned me a
bunch of money
and allowed me to quit everything else
and just say i'm a stuntman oh so
it it gave you some freedom gave me a
touch of freedom and it wasn't it was
like 20 grand
but it was enough for me to just say i
cannot i could stop doing anything else
and just say i'm a stuntman and just be
a stuntman
so you've been in the business for how
long nearly total
nearly 30 years yeah piano
fresh prince peeing on in the house how
did you get the job
as a pa on french prince i worked on a
morning
kids show called name your adventure and
it was via my brother's girlfriend that
got me the connection with the producer
i did a commercial one day
and i didn't know a clue i'd never been
in the business didn't know anything and
i became the second id on this uh body
by jake commercial yeah
and all i remember was just beautiful
girls and like
you know workout outfit i'm like this is
this is an amazing career
i might do this the rest of my life and
then i felt like it was a trap because
at the end of it the girls were like oh
you were so great
we should hang out sometime and i'm like
oh that's the trap that's the trap the
producers are watching this and then
you'll never work again so then i just
just backpedaled no i got to be over
here
you know just get nervous about
producers
i think it's almost i mean it's not mine
but it's really kind of dare devilish
stuff you know
it's their devil stuff well it's
calculated
that's that's that's the thing you know
we we do rehearse and we calculate
everything we do i mean
there's things you are risky and you
kind of it is a stunt for a reason
but so let's say when a writer's writing
a scene let's talk about
let's talk about one you did for born
jason bourne because i love those movies
when a writer is writing he writes that
the girl gets shot the car goes in the
water they go underneath he's under the
water he lets her go
and he goes back up right a lot of a lot
of are they assuming that that's
something that somebody
would be able to do or do they figure
that out later
they kind of well a lot of the time they
as they're writing it sometimes they
you know if it's obviously in a story
and that's they do give you all the
details of what is one thing but
a lot of the time they just kind of the
car goes off the edge
goes in the water and then they move
forward past the story on to what's
going on next and
it's up to the stunt coordinator and the
second-year director to design
what that entails the car going off the
edge what goes on with that car with the
people inside that car how their bodies
react when it hits the water
all those little details are left for us
to design
and come up with and then we'll work
with the facts and we'll work with the
other departments and
make it happen pretty much i remember uh
on my talk show i'd leave him nissan and
they were like oh liam neeson's you know
he's a tough interview
to watch a movie and he's in the back
seat he's underwater you know
it's him so i said you know i noticed
that you know when i saw the movie you
were in the backseat you're underwater
what was that like and he goes it was
[ __ ] scary
that's awesome because you're like what
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah he was a tough interview they said
but then like that you just you know
it just kind of loosens everybody up
because
he's out of his element anyway he's
telling you about that was he easier
after
after you yeah he broke them up yeah it
was very cool
so all i've had a ton of friends who
want to be stuntmen they all went to
stunt school
did you go to stunt school no there's
there's there's an old way of thinking
of that right
guys who run stunt schools often aren't
working because if you
if you're working you don't have time to
run a school
you know what i mean and so i mean
specialty schools maybe like a driving
sort of thing maybe you could do that
but no you can't run a stunt school and
and the things they teach you in stunt
school where remember that one joey
chick nick
name chipmunk joey chicks joey
what was that name like he had a stunt
school joey yeah
that's why i asked because you have
these friends that go i went to stunt
school and i don't know if that's like
what you got to do yeah no i know guys
have done it
they're they're always in like
washington or in some
yeah far off place that you'd actually
have to pay a lot of money to go to that
so you never like you just use guys i
just did martial arts and i
trained different stuff and then being
around the business pang you kind of
learned just how
people maneuver with their departments
you know
and so i talked to the stunt guys every
time that way yeah so
so they don't like when they hire you as
a stunt man
they go he's done this he's done that
he's like look at him fly through that
window kind of thing i mean
it's kind of like chicken before the egg
type
thing you gotta be a maid man already to
get a job right
you just have to kind of have you
there's like a swagger
when it comes to stunt people you know
what i mean you know who's yeah that guy
will go for it
it's joey chickwood oh
my gosh well done that's a great yeah
and you know what it's almost the
equivalent of getting a degree from
[ __ ] count college all right
[Music]
when frosty and i met at the chateau
marmont
he told me this incredible story
of us of a stunt that he did are you
comfortable trying to turn sure if it
if i know what it is that memory thing
the one where you got cut
uh cutting the stomach yeah yeah yeah
yeah fair enough um
yeah i uh i won't play the guitar this
this i did uh
this is a fat i mean you know this guy
right here is flesh and bones like us
yeah
but he he really is something beyond
that i mean
you look at somebody like i i think
that's one of the things maybe
that kept us like friends is i just have
so much respect for you as
thank you as a person and what you've
gone through and knowing that it hasn't
been easy but knowing also
that it's easier to just say it's a wrap
but you stayed in the business and i
think
coordinating is is is good because
you've put your time and as in the
military you started the private you go
and you get the bars and the stripes and
stuff and you've definitely earned your
stars and stripes thank you but the
first night we met
had never really met um anybody like
frosty
and you know 10 or 11 years later here
we are
yeah it uh yeah i i that was a new wound
at that point too when we were talking
about it was pretty fresh
i think i it happened 12 years ago now
so
yeah it was pretty fresh i um i did some
tv show and i normally just do features
i don't really do television
and so i did a tv show and um i won't
say it was just some
crappy show but uh it uh
you know everyone was like super powered
vampire type people
so i got thrown into a pillar and the
idea
was this vampire super strength chucks
me into a pillar and i hit the pillar
and just fly off
hit a table and fall to the ground but
the table and everything were out of
frame so
cool i just hit the pill yeah i'll do
that we tested
we'd come to film with the day and um
the director's like i love that do you
mind if we stick with you
and i'm like no it's fine i mean i'm
just gonna hit a table can you smash
through that table and i'm like
well it's a real table no yeah
i'm like i can give it a go but i lose a
lot of my energy on that pillar
so by the time i come off the pillar and
i hit the table the table's just going
to rock over it's not going to smash
well what if we score it yeah you could
score it um
i'll give it a go and scoring it is a
yes for like special effects where they
cut
it weaken it make it softer easier to
break through um
but on a real table and once it's like
brian's hymen yeah
it's very scored it's ready to blow but
it hasn't broken yet
i just i'm that big of a loser
what's your favorite when we pop your
cherry in here
cherry all right sorry thank you baby
i enjoy it i can listen to you guys all
day
and uh yeah so the director's like okay
we'll score it and when they score it
they scored in crosses
basically so sadly at the point on a
wooden table it leaves the very jagged
point
and you wear a body harness when they
launch you because you attach the wire
to your body harness so i had a full
harness on
when i went through the table i did
smash it but a piece of the wood
went under my harness and from hip bone
to hip bone gutted me pretty much
so you know and i knew we had one real
table
so i was kind of ahead of it and i was
already annoyed that this
gag was gonna happen this way anyway so
um
i do it i get cut up i don't say a word
i just stand up and they're like you
good
i give a thumbs up yeah i'm good they're
great we got that you can go
get out of your harness like go to my
trailer get out of my harness and i put
a wrap
around my waist and i and i just kind of
cinch it down so you can't tell when i
go walking back to set
and they're like you good i'm like yeah
yeah i'm good they're like well we got
that you can go home and i'm like
awesome
so i just took off i went home and i sat
down
on this chair i used to sit in at my
house and uh
i fell asleep i never went to a doctor i
fell asleep and then when i woke up
it tore back open oh so uh
i did call a doctor because i didn't
want to tell anyone so i called the
doctor in beverly hills figuring they
know what they're doing
and uh and it was the c-section sort of
thing
so hypothetically if a man got a
c-section
could you close that up and the doctor's
like i don't know what you're saying sir
well say hypothetically i got cut from
hip bone and hip bone
could you close that up sir you'd have
to come in so i went in he sewed me up
but it was all the way all the way oh
yeah it opened me up but
your your guts were hanging out well you
know
i mean it cut nothing yeah it was it was
ripped i mean i was bleeding pretty good
but it wasn't
nothing was pouring out of me like right
bits and pieces
and i kept myself kind of with this wrap
around me anyway
so yeah i uh yeah how many staples
no no that unfortunately i had a little
bit of time off after that gag and uh
i had uh i think it was like a hundred
and some odd stitches and
oh my god uh yeah i uh i didn't tell
anyone that so i kept working i kept
trying to do
as much as i could with this weird
little girdle thing going on and
yeah god man incredible and he showed me
the scar and i was
i was tripped out yeah it's an ugly scar
doctors in beverly hills didn't do a
very good job
yeah he didn't like brush it down at all
uh are you prepared to show us a scar
uh i could show you guys this guy yeah
yeah about national tv
okay yeah okay yeah but it was uh
something that i just thought
i mean to be cut from hip on the hip
bone
and not saying anything yeah and is
but it's funny yeah obviously you're
that ilka person but but knowing that
it's like a real table you weren't into
the whole thing
you you kind of smelled trouble already
right so yeah i i've had enough
experience to know
in the sense like this isn't this isn't
this isn't a great gag but
sadly a lot of time on television they
rush through things just because they
have to just for their time frames you
know
there's no choice of it but um i knew it
wasn't
it wasn't gonna it just it just had a
vibe to it that it wasn't gonna go well
listen man
uh i appreciate you coming down and
doing this you had the option to do a
skype
came down i appreciate your friendship i
love you as my brother
you know even though we don't see each
other this was awesome to spend this
time with you
and you i [ __ ] see all the time
seriously frosty that's so interesting
i mean so before we even we started this
you
these stories are amazing to me do you
think you'll remember any of this
tomorrow after you're saying
absolutely not after i finish this one
it's all gone i just know i owe somebody
five push-ups
so when he drinks he gets blacked out
like after two beers at one time we're
in chicago and
we were drunk and then this guy got in
my face and i was gonna fight the next
day i said
man i can't believe that dude was gonna
[ __ ] kick my ass try and you go what
when i said you were standing right next
to me all right everybody thank you for
tuning in to
oh my god hi with myself thank you frost
for being a guest
thank you guys brian for having me with
a big note
listen everybody thanks for listening to
all your friends wherever you get a
podcast
apple spotify you want to uh ask george
any question that's on your mind
ask him for any advice it's 818-533-1843
so thank you everybody for listening to
oh my god hi
on all things comedy say goodbye
everybody goodbye everybody
you